the United States has filed new charges
against WikiLeaks founder Julian Assange
they accuse him of violating the
Espionage Act when he published secret
documents containing the names of
confidential military and diplomatic
sources Assange supporters call the
charges a threat to press freedom the US
Justice Department's new indictment says
that Julian Assange directed former Army
Intelligence analyst Chelsea Manning to
illegally obtain classified information
the WikiLeaks founder then released the
sensitive documents to escape being
extradited to Sweden on rape charges
Assange was granted asylum in the
Ecuadorian Embassy in London where he
stayed for seven years before the
embassy evicted him in April because of
disputes the Ecuadorians then allowed
London police to arrest Assange
he is currently serving a 50 week jail
sentence for breaching bail Sweden is
also asking authorities for him to be
arrested on the rape charges and
extradited to Sweden previous US charges
accused Assange of conspiring with
Manning to crack a Defense Department
computer password free speech advocates
say the case is part of a wider
crackdown by the Justice Department on
national security leaks
it's got traditional news outlets
worried - searching out and publishing
classified information is part and
parcel of their work those same concerns
led the Obama administration Justice
Department to balk at bringing charges
for similar conduct the new charges
raised immediate questions about media
freedom